The image backing a canvas is represented in
Javascript with an Image Data object.
It contains values for the width, and height of the source image in pixels,
along with the data array containing the red, green, blue and
alpha values for each pixel.
The data property is usually represented by a U int eight clamped array.
Now I know that sounds a little bit confusing.
Let's break it down a bit.
The U means that their rate is unsigned or contains only positive values.
Int eight indicates that it will store 8-bit numbers.
8-bit positive numbers range from zero to 255.
If JavaScript was making it easy for
us, the data for one pixel would be separated from all the others like this.
Instead, it's one giant list you have to parse when you apply effects.
We can retrieve or modify the image data by calling one of these functions.
Create image data initializes a blank image data object that you can modify.
Getimagedata and putimagedata will retrieve or store data to a backing canvas.
So let's start with something simple.
Let's say we wanted to create an image and
make every tenth pixel a solid green color.
What code will we have to write to do that?
After you're finished, click here when you're done.